aber da willst du meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ihr seht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet neue omg fortnight 2
lukas 1 ich wollte mich so ein bisschen
den titeln der ford community anpassen
allerdings soll es heute nicht um
irgendwelche skins oder keine ahnung was
gehen sondern es geht darum das fordert
gestern das kapitel 2 vorgestellt hat
[Applaus]
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was das
ist allerdings würde ich sagen starten
einfach mal direkt rein in eine neue
runde fordert solo uns was wir sind noch
in der lobby das hier ist die neue
fordert web die die tage vorgestellt
wurde damit kann einfach mal auf einem
klicken und sehen ich habe schon
ziemlich viel davon erkundet ich würde
sagen wir steigen wieder einfacher als
allerletztes raus springen hier runter
ich habe keine ahnung was das er für
einen ort ist und allgemein habe ich
dieses neue fordert update erst einmal
richtig gespielt nämlich als das
rausgekommen dass die tage ich habe
allerdings direkt saft oder nimmt rang
wetter passt stufenaufstieg okay das
ging schnell ich glaube hier ist noch
irgendwo einer gelandet da hinten nehme
ich den kann ich nämlich direkt mal
[Musik]
hallo
ich bin einfach viel zu blöd für dieses
spiel wie komme ich denn jetzt hier
runter ich hab' ich hab keine munition
mehr was ist ich habe schaden wenn ich
hab keine ahnung warum ich hier oben
drauf gelandet bin ich habe eine
ziemlich karg waffe bekommen ich habe
auch nur noch 980 leben aber noch 50 von
dem fuß drauf ich weiß aber nicht was an
[Musik]
nur du kannst betrügereien mit wie bugs
verhindern teile dein passwort nicht mit
dritten ja mein passwort ist besser
fordert spieler 69
verpiss dich du ich würde sagen wir
steigen diesmal auch wieder als
allerletztes aus und zwar gehen wir
dahin den den den ort da vorne kenne ich
auf jeden fall schon mehr oder weniger
also die erste runde die ich hier
gezockt habe gestern oder sogar das
glaube ich gestern morgen da bin ich
halt hier gelandet direkt und kenne mich
da ich schon sonnen ja so ein prozent
kenne ich da schon ich bin halt wirklich
kein krasser fordert spieler und ich
glaube man braucht bei vorteilen auch
nicht unbedingt viel sondern einfach nur
übung also es ist jetzt nicht so wie
singen oder so dass man da schon mit
fast vergleich das eigentlich hier
gerade ich glaube auch wenn man
unfassbar schlechten fordert ist wenn
man einfach genug spielt dann kann jeder
einen profi werden so und ich habe
leider einfach nicht die zeit dazu die
ganze zeit zu zocken bzw auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht so ganz die motivation weil
ich glaube der zug bei mir ist schon
längst abgefahren als erster spieler
match maximale kondition und schilder
wenn es eine sache gibt die ich kann
dann ist es das war doch ich bin scheiße
dem spiel ich weiß ich bin ziemlich
beschissen nach fordert spieler im
andere würden sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
genau das würden profis machen luca
allerdings machte das spiel spaß und ich
finde das wichtigste im leben ist dass
man spaß hat
ob der aus spaß schränkt sie unten in
die kommentare
realtech ich habe absolut keinen plan
was in dieser neuen fordert diesen
hinzugekommen ist ich glaube es ist halt
eine neue map am start bzw
das heißt ich glaube man sieht ja dass
es eine neue map ist ich weiß dass
irgendwelche werkbänke dazugekommen sind
also man kann sich jetzt auch sachen so
richtig kräften wenn man halt irgendwie
bei materialien hat aber das ist noch
ziemlich teuer deswegen werden wir das
auf gar keinen fall machen
ich hab' ich habe eine überlebens
medaille bekommen weil ich unter den top
naja da merkt man wie selten nicht das
spiel spielt und die scheiße ich auch
eigentlich mit nur wenige minuten später
und 70 erst wird wirklich nicht oh mein
gott
aber der eben den anderen getötet
achtung
ach du scheiße der kann baunach du
scheiße ich kann nicht bauen
ach das ist ja not gegen elend egal da
ich habe angst
mit kopfschuss eliminiert oder zu boden
geschickt ya ha ha ha leg dich mit mir
nicht zu boden geschickt werden willst
du mein gott er schaut mir doch ich
denke auch luca um mein gott das ist
jetzt nicht warten das ist jetzt nicht
wahr dass das ist nicht wahr ich sterbe
doch jetzt nicht wegen der zone
das ist nicht wahr dass es sich sein
herz das ist nicht sein ernst die bleibt
da vorne stehen das ist nicht das ist
nicht einfach da lernt mein leben es
eine reinste enttäuschung
[Musik]
es geht los ich würde sagen wir spielen
jetzt komplett rennt immer einfach mal
hier raus und gehen dahin dass ist
schiff die ja ich habe keine ahnung ob
ich richtig liege mit dem namen ich
glaube das heißt irgendwie schiff die
springs oder irgendwie sowas lese und
park genau schauen wir uns doch einfach
mal in diesem haus hier oben ich habe
keine ahnung wo a ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
direkten tranken stade er kann sehr
schön rein sippel in gin tonic haben wir
uns hier vorne mal so ein kleines
guckloch rein damit wir direkt auf mein
gott plötzlich hörte ich alle nicht
richtig wir bauen uns mal ganz leise
hier dahin vorhanden wer genug sachen
zeigt auf die eins wünschen er auf die 2
und da wissen der hin ist er hier drin
so blöd nur dass auch du blöde sau du
wirst du machst noch den spaß am spiel
kampf ein alter da wo gehen wir dann
diesmal hände aber ich würde sagen wir
fliegen mal nach vorne ich bin
vielleicht ein bisschen zu spät
ausgestiegen haben aber jetzt gerade
erst gesehen
das ist ein kernkraftwerk sofern ich das
richtig beurteilen kann ich lande
einfach mal wieder hier oben auf dem
turm ich bin ja vorher auch schon mal
auf dem turm darauf gelandet waren
eigentlich ganz neue sachen drin genau
haben wir direkten trank den ziehen wir
uns rein den anderen ziehen wir uns auch
rein und dann switchen auf die waffe und
die nach hinten
erst der eliminierung image wetter passt
vier ich bin krank ich soll auch so
tritscher es allerdings werden wenn paar
sekunden später ja wie komme ich denn
jetzt wieder hier runter ich hoffe dass
es wasser und ich hoffe ich kann da rein
springen wir haben es überlebt
raus hier genau perfekt und jetzt
schauen wir uns mal hier ein bisschen um
ich weiß nicht was das für ein komischer
raum hier ist aber ja nix aber ich weiß
nicht wo ich bin ja so sehen eigentlich
99 prozent meiner fortnight runden aus
da seien wieder seine angel
ich nehme die nehme ich einfach mal mit
kann ich ja ich kann im wasser angeln
gehen wir jetzt allerdings mal die angel
und angeln hier ein bisschen wie
funktioniert das wird allerdings sagen
wir bewegen uns dann mal wieder so ein
bisschen in richtung zone weil vorhin
lief ist ja nicht so gut mit der zone
das ist
ernst ist das jetzt minecraft hier dass
man das darunter abbauen kann
oder ist es einfach ich glaube das waren
grafikfehler ich will allerdings setzt
man endlich ein bisschen action hier
haben hier fordert auf jeden fall eine
treppe gebaut das heißt sich jetzt
einfach mal neuer orientierungspunkt der
obstgarten 11 watt für eine scheiße ich
hier allerdings ein sturmgewehr alles
echt wahnsinn was ich für ne scheiße
hier punkte bekomme ich höre geballer
aha das ding kommt erst noch ich würde
sagen wir warten einfach mal ganz
gediegen hier vorne auf dem dach damit
uns auch wirklich keiner erkennen so der
internist einer achtung form stimmt
nicht
wir stehen unter beschuss
und da hinten ist man stirbt doch jetzt
könnt ihr einfach mal ein bisschen lahm
und wo ich jetzt hier gerade am schön
wenn unterm warten bin die sache ist ich
habe eigentlich bock mal wieder öfter
vorne zu bringen oder vorne geht ab da
geht erwarte ich bauen wir hier noch so
ein ding ich mir noch eine treppe genau
und dahinter noch ein
und jetzt kann ich ein bisschen so ja
aber deshalb keine hab ich habe
eigentlich bock mal wieder öfter fordert
auf meinem kanal zu bringen habe mir
früher quasi wöchentlich was hochgeladen
ich habe auch viele coole ideen ich
hatte bock mal wieder ruckelt das und
gerade so entstehen
verdammte scheiße dass das
erklären ich will geistig nicht ganz
gesund an der ich das heutige fordern
dagegen jetzt allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat das unternehmen einen
daumen hoch unter dem video haben
schreibt mir gern nochmal uns in die
kommentare
ob ich in zukunft wieder öfter fortnight
hochladen soll hier auf einem kanal
ich habe halt in den letzten monaten
immer so ein fehler dass ich das spiel
nicht zocken konnte deswegen habe ich
auch seit dem halben jahr oder einem
jahr oder so keine vorteile mehr
hochgeladen
aber ich hätte auf jeden fall bock drauf
ich finde das neue update mega cool ich
hatte zum beispiel box ganz normal mit
sandra zu spielen oder mal wieder mit
jule haben dass wir auf jeden fall ganz
lustig schreibt noch den verkehr den
kommentare was sie davon halten und
abonniert gern main kanal und im video
wenn ihr keine videos mehr verpassen
wollte
[Musik]